unity 2020
here's the here's the deal it is going
great at one level
we are discovering the most amazing set
of patriots these are people who are
um frightened about where we're headed
people who love their country and are
ready to sacrifice
for it and they are showing up to offer
all kinds of help skills that we
definitely need
so things are rapidly in motion as i
have mentioned before
there is a curious lack the people who
tell us that they are very much on board
with the plan
do not always do anything that allows us
to count them
so that we can say how many people are
actually rooting for us and
i wanted to talk a little bit about why
i think that might be so before you talk
about why
you think there's a failure somewhere
why don't you say
both here why don't you bracket this
conversation by saying what
what should be happening what would you
like people to be doing
well here's the long and short of it the
long and short of it is there is exactly
one thing that we do not have and this
plan could
actually work believe it or not it is
not too late everything that needs to
happen
can happen what we need is a visible
ground swell
of american citizens eligible to vote
right but what where do they sign up
where's the place that you want them to
be signing up we want them to go to the
website
articlesofunity.org you will find
there are links to offer your volunteer
support to sign up
for our email list and let us know um
where you are and what you're thinking
so please do that you should also
follow our twitter account if you are on
twitter articles of unity at articles of
unity
those are the places to go there will be
more opportunities
showing up this week and so anyway those
are the places to sign up for you to
find out about what is emerging
and yes we are looking for your help but
really you want to do something for us
find two people with ears to hear and
tell them that's it
two people and then you ask them can you
find two people
that'll work right you won't know that
will have happened unless they also sign
up unless they show up at those
at those uh addresses yeah all right so
now i want to talk to you
i'm noticing i need to center myself
a little bit more in the shot okay um
here's the
model that i came up with as i was
driving back from dropping
zach at his uh bicycle maintenance
course that he is taking what i realized
was that we are hearing
pushback from a couple of quadrants and
one of those quadrants
are people who say things to us like
um this sounds like a great plan how
about waiting until 2024
when we've already allowed joe biden to
clear donald trump from the white house
etc etc could you please just show this
plan
seems really cool but i gotta say that
sounds like a great idea because it will
give all of the enemies of the plan much
more time to organize and
and get their [ __ ] together i hadn't
even thought of that that's a great
point
here's the thing if you are somebody who
has been alarmed about the corruption of
our system and the role that the duopoly
plays in that corruption if you've been
aware of that for decades then you know
that every single election cycle we go
through this
right you say you know what this is not
going to solve itself the duopoly has
a lock on power and that lock on power
is being used to serve interests that
are not the interests of the american
people
what are we going to do about it if you
just go through the normal channels
go through the normal channels but if
you say well we've done that and it
doesn't work
and you say maybe we have to do
something else what happens next is
people say
ah if you do something else you will
elect the greater evil and this will be
your fault
right and nobody wants to be your fault
yeah right um we've seen that happen to
people like ralph
2020 is being set up to explain the
re-election of trump
right when in fact we can squarely point
at the dnc well
first of all the dnc is responsible for
this in more ways than one
the rnc as well the duopoly has played
tag team
with their little corruption racket and
uh so
in any case you will hear each election
cycle you will hear
you're going to elect the greater evil
and this is going to be your fault
and then if you persist you will be told
well you can't do it this time because
of the supreme court right this is just
every single every single election cycle
it's amazing the supreme court always
seems to be
on the verge of retirement and collapse
it's funny it's almost as if it's
staffed by mortals who have a lifespan
and
ultimately end up retiring and need to
be replaced so it's never the time for
something new not to suggest that the
makeup of the supreme court isn't
critical but
it's it's always sort of i don't know
what was that the second or the third
rejoinder to
um it has to be now well let's put it
this way the
fact that it is critical this time is
not an argument against something
different because it only gets more
critical over time so if you think it's
critical now and that's the reason not
to do it
you've actually got it backwards now is
the time we have to do it because next
time it's going to be even more critical
so many people are suggesting going back
in time if they have a mechanism i'm all
ears
but in any case here's the thing
i've heard so many times that you can't
do it because you'll elect the greater
evil the whole structure of this plan is
built to address that concern
right we don't have that problem because
we have structurally
um built a mechanism that will not spoil
the election
so in spite of that fact
we are getting this pushback from
certain people who say
lovely plan all ears do it in 2024 and
we'll get
we'll get on board but not now because
of the problem so i want to
tell you about my model that i came up
with as i was driving back
the model is this for many people donald
trump
is the equivalent of a rock in your shoe
right if you've ever had a rock in your
shoe and we've all had rocks in our shoe
right
a rock in your shoe is top priority it's
very hard to ignore right every step it
reminds you that this has to be dealt
with and there are a lot of people
who are experiencing trump as the rock
in their shoe that needs to be dealt
with
but we've got a rock in our shoe at the
same time that we've got
basically the equivalent of a famine
right we have a duopoly
that has concentrated its power and
built a system that you can never escape
and it has essentially denied
people access to the policy mechanisms
that are supposed to serve their
needs and this has gone on for decades
and because of that
people are not only frozen out of the
well-being that they produce through
their labor
but they are also aware of it and
they're sick of it they know that the
system is rigged they may not know
exactly in what way it is rigged
but they're angry and here's the
important point
whether or not the rock in the shoe is
the one
thing you can think of or it's one on a
set of high priorities that all have to
be addressed has to do
in some sense with how threatened by the
famine you are if you're especially well
positioned in society
then from your perspective it may well
make sense we have to deal with the rock
in our shoe because even in a famine you
wouldn't want to leave a rock in your
shoe because
whatever you're going to do to deal with
the famine getting the rock out of your
shoe first makes sense so
if you're not directly threatened by the
famine then you will think rocking your
shoe is the only thing we got and you'll
say stuff like well why don't you wait
till 2024
right let's deal with the rock in our
shoe and then 2024 we can deal with the
famine but for anybody who's
either starving or threatened with
starvation that doesn't make any sense
because the rock in the shoe is a high
priority and the famine is a high
priority and we're going to have to do
something to deal with both of them
maybe we got to get the rock out
but we've also got to deal with the
famine and here's an election in which
you could do both
could i read to you a couple of
sentences from an excellent document
that i found from almost 10 years ago
please do recent decades this is from
2011.
recent decades have witnessed a de facto
coup against the democratic structures
of the world
and the wholesale capture and sabotage
of the entire public regulatory
apparatus
the co-opted structures have been
redirected and now serve to liquidate
the world's resources and concentrate
wealth and power in the hands of a tiny
unelected elite only the costs remain
public
and it goes on this is from the
declaration of interdependence
which you wrote during occupy and which
proceeds to make a number of highly
specific and actionable bullet points
about
what to do just to the argument that not
now
not now please wait until next time when
there's a greater chance of success when
there will presumably be no
two evils to choose between this was the
first time that i know that you had
formalized
in writing some of exactly the concerns
that you have laid out in the first
whatever five minutes of this livestream
today
this is from 2011. that's amazing thank
you you know i have thought
frequently during this unity 2020 phase
i've thought about that document and i
just
literally have not had the time to go
find it um but yeah i wrote the
declaration of interdependence and it's
it uh
lays out exactly the problem and what
that tells you is that
the fact that that uh bit that you read
there is equally applicable
today that tells you some of us have
been aware of this for quite some time
and we've tried to call people's
attention to it and what people have
been is too calm to address it yeah and
you know let me say that you know we we
as as we have been making clear
throughout
you know had been anyway still are
lifelong democrats
liberals progressives uh you know much
to the irritation of some in our
audience but
um this was written in 2011. this was
written during
obama's first term we we were so
hopeful about obama in the beginning and
that does not mean that we did not
critique
during his his first and certainly his
second term what it was that was
actually being accomplished
after that great rhetorical movement
that actually got him elected and it was
that's what it was it was rhetoric
it was a rhetoric it was a rhetorical
movement you're absolutely right about
that and you know
i still like a lot of the rhetoric but
the fact that it's great it didn't
translate into policy that served people
and what that tells you
is that the duopoly i mean
let's face facts folk they they don't
want to solve the problem
not because they wouldn't ideally like
to do it also but it is
counterproductive from the point of view
of the thing that they actually do
which is deliver well-being to a small
number of very powerful entities that
have bought access
right it's it's an influence peddling
racket so we shouldn't expect them we
should expect them to deliver us
rhetoric and symbolism and um false
solutions
um until we finally get wise to it and
my point would be
well maybe it's time we finally got wise
to it i mean collectively
enough that we can actually evict them
from the positions from which
they capture all of the well-being that
should be widely available and
deliver it to their own yeah it's really
uh
it's quite a thing but if you are
hearing the same thing we are hearing if
you are hearing people say well that's a
cool plan
how about we try that in 2024 think
about whether or not the people who are
telling you that are really telling you
that from their perspective the famine
isn't such a big deal
because on the whole the duopoly has
probably inadvertently in most of their
cases
serve their interest just by virtue of
where in society they are
and for people who are closer to the
bottom of the ladder or who have fallen
off the bottom of the ladder
this has been critical for decades right
the danger to
to working people is so extreme that now
we see
uh quite predictable uh movements in the
street of people
frankly shouting incoherently to tear
the thing down
because all they can see is the harm
that it does because that harm is
concentrated where they are
so um that is all very important
now i would point to the last thing here
which is really the place that's harder
that i find hardest to make the point
it has long been true that the
democratic party in particular has
delivered symbolism
in lieu of actual well-being right
that's been their go-to strategy
this character did you say he's
particularly uh
prone to that well it's not that one
party is particularly prone to it
it's that the democratic party has
traditionally served the interests of
working people
and so having shifted away from that now
it has to deliver symbolism
in lieu of actual policy you know
symbols are cheaper
they are cheaper but in this case the
symbols have begun to run out people
aren't buying it anymore right we went
through eight years of obama and things
did not get better
so we know that the rhetoric doesn't add
up to policy that actually serves people
we know that we still have
um you know a system of medical care for
example that people can't access and
that
is dependent on their relationship with
their employer and that the economic
system is fragile in the way it's
constructed and so you can lose your
health care
you know at the drop of a hat um so what
has changed is the democratic party
seems to be toying with a mechanism to
deliver
many people who are stressed out by what
i'm calling the famine
to deliver them something but the
something that they're going to deliver
is well-being that currently is um
held by other people who are in a
similar strata in other words
the intersectional thing is about
pointing people who are angry about
having been frozen out
redirecting them away from the places
where well-being is actually
concentrated and pointing them at
another group of citizens and this is
the most deeply unpatriotic move you can
imagine pointing americans at each other
rather than dealing with the fact that
opportunity has concentrated at the top
is just the pollen to use the um
the pie analogy the zero-sum non-zero
sum uh
language that we have used uh it is
possible
that growth some growth in some sectors
can continue but even if we assume that
we are in zero sum space
at a national level with regard to
well-being and i'm not saying that
that's true but even if we assume that
what you are saying if i if i hear you
correctly is there is some some pie
um for you know and this is going to be
hard to operationalize but you know
for well-being which is you know to some
degree the good proxy is resources there
for all of americans and
what you were pointing out is that the
elite the one percent
the people with power um have observed
that a number of people
are seeing this you know since occupy
since before then
right and saying well if we can pit
some of the kind of halves against the
um
recognizing have-nots against each other
we can redefine what the pie actually is
to be that very tiny sliver of the
actual pie while we keep all the rest of
it so it's like a pie within a pie
and the people with most of it are
successfully redefining what the actual
pie
is and causing the rest of us to fight
amongst ourselves yeah
so i was toying with the idea that
biden was the let the meat cake
candidate that that's really the
nature of joe biden at the moment and
you
uh fixed that analogy beautifully
remember what you said not at the moment
you said
no he used to let them eat their cake
candidate oh yeah because
in this sea and let them eat cake
there's no cake that's the point the
the rent-seeking elites in the monarchy
don't understand
that there's no cake right and so that's
an absolute only they have cake only
they have cake right so they think cake
is everywhere right in this case
um there is cake well there's an
abundance of
there's such an abundance of cheap goods
that were exactly the things that were
limiting until like a second ago
historically speaking
that yeah let them eat their cake cake's
available right and so in this case
instead of taking the
you know and again we have to draw a
distinction between um the productivity
of elites which actually serves
everybody and the rent seeking
of people who become powerful some of
them have gotten powerful through being
highly productive and contributing
things that matter but once they are
productive it's very hard to resist they
don't even necessarily know that they
are engaged in
rent seeking there are just
opportunities that pay and they do that
which pays and many of those
opportunities are
rent seeking by definition so the dnc
has decided to point us at each other
and the basic point is well
there's not enough cake but if this
group goes after the cake of that group
then the rent seeking elites can
continue on for another four
eight who knows how many election cycles
for eight years
the baked goods analogy gets twisted but
uh it's like a cupcake within a pie
well there are twisted baked goods not
that many but um
some very you know like a delicious one
too yeah all right
so anyway that's the developing model
yeah and here's the question um
presumably if you're watching or
listening to this podcast
you're you're wise to this stuff you're
aware of game theory
you're aware of what rent-seeking is and
why it's a hazard
you're aware of the evolutionary forces
that will take
a corrupt system and make it more
corrupt because the loopholes will tend
to self-enlarge
so if you can see it then isn't this the
moment
wouldn't you like in four months for us
to have turned the corner for something
unexpected new and potentially very
desirable to have happened
wouldn't you like adults at the helm i
mean don't you have a right to demand
that as an american have adults at the
helm don't we all
so how about it